do you have advice for young people
you're
have a fascinating life journey
is there advice you can give to people
in high school and
college about
how to have a
life like yours in whatever pursuit
in terms of
success is such a
silly word
but just find
success
or maybe happiness
in career or just in life in general
yeah i would the only advice i i would
have would be to not listen to anyone
and to do what you love
and to make things that you love
whatever it is make make your favorite
things
be the audio be the audience make the
thing for you the audience
and
it doesn't it doesn't really matter what
anyone else thinks and if you have to
get a job to support yourself so that
you can make your art that's fine it
you can't make art for someone else you
can't make art with someone else in mind
i don't believe i don't believe it can
be good
so what does success feel like are you
are you grateful are you
proud of the work you've done in the
past or is there some engine of constant
dissatisfaction like self-criticism of i
could have done better
no i'm i'm
pleased with the work that we did
excited to keep working it's fun it's i
don't know what else i would do with
myself because it i like the uh
i like making things it's fun i feel
like it's my uh reason to be on the
planet so i just keep doing it
whatever ideas are actually coming from
elsewhere and are using your mind as a
temporary vehicle
that's their purpose to be on this
planet your your purpose is to procreate
and not die
and eat
regularly enough such that the brain uh
is alive it's a biological purpose yeah
and anything i can do to keep the
channel open to allow what wants to come
through to come through i'm a i'm a
willing channel it's so interesting
because i i'm extremely self-critical so
you don't have that
self-criticism harsh like
this could have been better this
uh if it could have been better i would
keep working on it
it's like it's if it's not if it could
be better it's not done
it's the one that's done it's the best
it can well it's the best it can be
i've done everything i can to make it
the best it can be
and that's i can't do more than that so
there's nothing to be critical of i did
my very if you always do if you always
give all of yourself and do your best
which you're capable of doing you're not
you're i'm not suggesting that you're
capable of doing more than you can do
but whatever it is that you can do if
you've given all of yourself to it
you've done your best
where is it where could there be regret
yeah i mean
there could be you re-listen to an album
you listen to or anything you've created
and and think oh there's so many
interesting ideas missed
it's fine though but that was that
moment it's like everything is like a um
it's almost like a diary entry
everything we make is a is a reflection
of a moment in time a window in time
could be a day
it could be a year it could be a you
know it could be whatever window you
decide that it is
um but if you give it all of yourself
and you know if you're not interested in
working it on it anymore it's done
now you may decide it's not good enough
to
share with people and that's fine but if
it's good enough to share with people
there's no regret looking back
that's funny because it like think of it
as a diary entry
it's hard to look back at a dire entry
and say you know i did it wrong i did it
wrong it's
impossible yeah
and even if it's
read by
a hundred people a thousand people a
million people it's just a diary entry
it doesn't matter
you